I'm Christie Duffy for SmarTrend News.
McDonald's is the world's number one fast food company by sales,...
...with more than 32,400 restaurants serving burgers and fries in more than 100 countries.
There are nearly 14,000 McDonald's locations in the United States.
The popular chain is well-known for its Big Macs, Quarter Pounders, and Chicken McNuggets.
Most of the outlets are freestanding units offering dine-in and drive-through service,...
...but McDonald's also has many eateries located in airports, retail areas, and other high-traffic locations.
About 80 percent of the restaurants are run by franchisees or affiliates.
I'm Christie Duffy for SmarTrend News.
For more on McDonald's stock, check our website: www.tradethetrend.com.
You can also find more company profiles on our YouTube channel: TradeTheTrend.